fifteen years ago this weekend an
article for The Guardian journalist been
Hamersley suggested a name for something
happening in online radio a broadcast
that people could listen to on Apple
iPods
he called it podcasting since that term
was coined there are now more than six
hundred and thirty thousand podcasts
covering everything from penmanship to
puppy rearing and almost every week
somebody you've heard of has launched a
new one in the Dark Ages of podcasting
it was not certain that the informal
sometimes homegrown experiments would
endure that's when I joined the fray
with two slate magazine colleagues Emily
Bazelon and David Platz for a political
podcast based on the conversations about
the news that we had during our walks to
lunch about fourteen years later and
none of us write for slate anymore but
the political gab fest continues each
week including occasional live shows
which is where we all recently talked
backstage about why this format survived
in Basel on Slate political gabfest for
14 years I successfully introduced the
show and that's all I have podcasts have
basically just been invented nobody was
listening so didn't matter returning
again to the question of Barack Obama's
tour he went to Iraq Afghanistan when
did we realize this was a Germany we did
our live show right after Obama's
inauguration she doesn't know how
surprised we were we were like oh my god
because normally the show takes place in
a space
well 150th the size of this to me that
the moment that really started the show
was it was from the 2008 campaign when
Edwards the Edwards story Edwards was
having an affair for me it always comes
down to the hubris of these men had a
big fight and we had a huge screaming
fight bombs everywhere do you think he
was doing in the hall I don't know and
it was after the official show had ended
but but they we had run the tape and
then we aired it tonight we tackle the
philosophical questions that you
actually think about who would give up
their arm for the Internet I think we're
all fairly performative and we feed off
of it who would not give up your arm for
the Internet do you know what this would
sound like after that was done a lot of
times at the cocktail parties before
hands a son will introduce me to a
mother or there's a so I don't know what
that's about I think it's a way that
people generate conversations within
their family gives them a starting place
and then they have the dinner table or
dinner party conversation they are
having in their heads when they're
listening are you accusing us of
bringing people together yeah I went to
Washington in 1995 people who don't
necessarily have a safe or a comfortable
way to talk about politics sometimes and
they need like for those of who grown up
with us or spend time with us it's a
it's a I'm not gonna use the word safe
space but the safe space to listen and
learn a little bit about politics and
then and then take that out to their
family most of my classes are with Emily
and I know I'm gonna
sometimes people ask me whether we
arranged beforehand like we were arguing
about the legacy of George HW Bush do
you think there's been some instinct to
just kind of whitewash his record
especially because we're trying to draw
a contrast with Trump and I just like
don't appreciate it to me what I love
about our disagreements is that they
always come from a place of honesty I'm
gonna give you the last word I might
have you know before you give her the
last word I would like at my funeral for
people to say 30% of what they said it
George
even when we heatedly disagree we do it
basically with a certain level of
respect and engagement listening to each
other and that's actually something
people really appreciate it's never just
to win the fight so I have to say I'm a
frequent gabfest listen all right listen
to your most recent one yesterday or
Valentine's episode and I was telling
you this morning that I'm surprised the
given you're always in different
locations how you don't talk over each
other that quality of editing yeah yeah
there's because there's usually a lot of
very heated debate and so people don't
usually don't often take turns but I'm
glad I'm glad it sounded good no it does
it always sounds good and I love that
you bring in so many people for your
live show I didn't know you'd been doing
it for so long that's what I think it's
so interesting I think I even learned
the term podcast maybe five years ago
maybe so I think you have a hit on your
head yeah he gave burden to the other it
gave birth to the whistle stop podcast
which came out of the cocktail chatter
we do have so podcasts beget podcasts so
what's the next big thing John I the
weekend is just trying to get well it's
a great podcast
I do dance